the trailheads of the baker creek road
the start of a journey for those who
choose to take the first step
it's a journey which some undertake for
adventure for exercise or just out of a
sense of discovery
but for one remarkably stubborn fish
it's a voyage already begun some fifteen
thousand years ago out of pure necessity
this trail hugs baker creek all the way
to tree line some six uphill miles
and like the thin string of a child's
helium balloon baker creek tethers its
namesake lake to the ranches and alfalfa
fields of snake valley a full vertical
mile below
on a scale of geologic time these
ranches are new to the land
what existed there before was a lake
fed by mountain glaciers and inhabited
by among other fantastic creatures the
bonneville cutthroat trout
the planet has changed a lot over the
course of millennia the organisms which
inhabit it and the atmosphere which
sustains them
our species has affected both
lake bonneville as we now refer to that
ancient lake is long gone the bonneville
cutthroat trout hangs on having fled the
dying lake and moved up hill to the
mountain streams of the great basin
including the snake range in eastern
nevada
like all trout bonnevilles require cold
oxygen-rich water
their numbers within great basin
national park already decimated by the
introduction of aggressive non-native
trout like this brook trout a warming
planet harbors no good news for one of
nevada's few native trout so an idea was
hatched
if non-native trout could be removed
from baker lake and johnson lake to the
south bonnevilles could be introduced
their species could in essence be
transported back in time and temperature
to conditions in which their pleistocene
ancestors thrived
two high altitude lakes which would
prove colder and more stable than the
small drought-prone streams where they
live now
one problem baker lake's natural outlet
flows underground for a short distance
before percolating to the surface it's a
journey that even a resourceful trout
like the bonneville cutthroat cannot
follow on its own
so john reynolds a fish biologist at
great basin national park plans to give
them an assist
his plan is to remove the lake's
non-native fish and deliver by hand its
rightful occupants the bonneville
cutthroat trout
it's a project in its early stages and
john's in recon mode tracking down the
lake's current non-native inhabitants
he's doing the legwork
this high elevation fortress of water
and stone will hopefully prove a
long-term sanctuary from human-driven
climate change
but it will likely not be a permanent
one
the waters of baker lake will eventually
warm as well but this move may just give
the bonneville cutthroat trout a
fighting chance to hold on to their
birthright in the waters of the snake
range at great basin national park